What If gravity switched directions for
10 seconds the first thing that would
happen is everything on Earth would be
pulled upwards causing catastrophic
damage to infrastructure and
disorientation for our bodies an
unexpected consequence would be the
atmosphere behaving like a liquid making
it harder to breathe near the surface
and easier for planes and spacecraft to
fly this brief switch in gravity would
require us to rethink the way we build
structures and move around it would also
have significant implications for space
travel potentially making launches
easier and more efficient after those 10
seconds we would need to rebuild and
adapt to our new reality though unlikely
to occur this event shows us how much we
depend on gravity and how much it
affects our lives